for the skills though that means uh that
means hiring and it means training yes
yes oh boy that's a long skills is a
really long Topic in and of itself I try
to put my view in it I learned a lot and
I changed my view on this a lot
um
I'll go back at my very beginning say 40
years ago I I would have said
at that point okay I was always in a
hurry I was interviewing to hire people
I don't know how you hire people 40
years ago I'd be like okay I gotta fit
in these interviews I gotta hire someone
to get this done okay then time would go
on I'm like oh that's not very good in
fact someone once said to me hey hire
the best people to work for you and your
job gets a lot easier okay I should
spend more time on this topic I spend
more time on it then it was like okay
hire experts okay okay hired a lot of
experts over my life
and then I was really like an epiphany
and it really happened over my tenure
running the company having to change
skills
if someone's an expert at something and
has just done that for 30 years
the ads of them really wanting to change
a lot are pretty low and when you're in
a really Dynamic industry that's a
problem and so okay that was like kind
of my first revelation on this and then
when I looked to hiring
I can remember when I started my job we
needed cyber people and I go out there
and I look unemployment in the US was
almost 10 can't find them okay it's 10
and I can't find the people okay what's
the issue okay they're not teaching the
right things
that led me down a path and it was
Serendipity that I happened to do a
review of social Corporate social
responsibility we had this one little
fledgling School in a low-income area
and high school with a community college
we gave them internships Direction on
curriculum
behold we could hire these kids
I said Hmm this is not CSR like I just
found a new talent pool which takes me
to now what I'm doing in my post you
know post retirement I'm like this idea
that don't hire just for a college
degree we had 99 of our hires were
college and phds and I'm all for it so
you're very don't I'm deeply excited no
you should not be I and I you know I'm
Vice chair at Northwestern one of the
device here but but I said I just really
like aptitude does not equal access
these people didn't have access but they
had aptitude it changed my whole view to
skills first and so now for hiring
that's kind of a long story to tell you
the number one thing I would hire for
now is somebody's willingness to learn
you know and you can test you can try
different ways but their curiosity and
willingness to learn hands down I will
take that trait over anything else they
have so the interview process the
question changes everything changed the
kind of things you talk to them about is
try to get at how curious they are about
testing and I mean there's we
triangulated around lots of ways and now
look they're at the heart of it what it
would do is change you don't think of
buying skills you see you think of
building skills and when you think that
way with so many people and I think this
country many developed countries being
disenfranchised
you got to bring them back into the
workforce somehow and they got to get
some kind of contemporary skills and if
you took that approach you can bring
them back into the workforce yeah I
think some interesting combination of
humility and passion because like you
said uh experts sometimes lack humility
if they call themselves an expert for a
few too many years so you have to have
that beginner's mind and a passion to be
able to aggressively constantly be a
beginner at everything and learn and
learn and learn you know I I saw it
firsthand when we were beginning this
path you know down the cloud in Ai and
we said and people say oh IBM you know
it's existential they've got to change
and all these things and and I did hire
a lot of people from outside very
willing to learn new things come on in
come on in
and I sometimes say shiny objects
trained in shiny objects come on in but
I saw something it was another one of
these you're not a shiny object I'm not
saying that it's uh but I learned
something okay some of them did
fantastic
and others they're like well let me
school you on everything but they didn't
realize like we did really Mission
critical work and then break a bank I
mean they would not understand the
certain kind of security and the
auditability and everything they had to
go on and then I watched IBM people say
oh I actually could learn something some
were like yeah okay I don't know how to
do that's a really good thing I could
learn and in the end there was not like
one group was a winner one was a loser
the winners were the people who were
willing to learn from each other I mean
it was to me it was very Stark example
of that point and I and I saw it
firsthand so that's why I'm so committed
to this idea about skills first and
that's how people should be hired
promoted paid you name it yeah the AI in
general it seems like nobody really
understand is now
what the future will look like we're all
trying to figure it out so like what you
know IBM will look like in 50 years uh
in relation to the the software business
to AI is unknown what Google will look
like with all these companies were
trying to figure it out out and that
means constantly learning
taking risks all of those things and
nobody's really skilled in AI It's like
because you're absolutely right that's
right